hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign organ and
today's video we're gonna be talking
about the new season thirteen or a year
for season one faction war and what
those rewards are which is ornaments
emblems and a new outline and of course
going over who those winners are what
those winners get and everything that's
gonna be detailed in today's video so a
lot like the V if you do enjoy subscribe
if you're new let's get started with
today's video so first up is the winners
and the winners go like this the Vikings
are in first place again with the
samurai in second and the unites and
third the Knights in samurai actually
tied for the amount of territories or
the amount of campaigns that they had
won within that kind of section of the
campaign but the Knights came in last
because in the event of a tiebreaker
it's based on troop deployment and they
had two percent less so the Knights got
third and I know every season we get new
players so I'll be explaining some
things because of the newer players that
may not understand so as for the rewards
was going to be ornaments emblems and
outlines in three colours depending on
the placement of your faction the
winners will get everything we're about
to bring up second place will be getting
only emblems and outline and third is
only going to be the outline and
speaking of that the first up is the
outline and this outline looks the same
for each faction of course taking into
account the different dimensions that
the emblem it being square shield circle
whatever faction you picked you get the
point but the changes our first place
gets a gold color second is silver and
third is bronze in the case of this
season specifically the Vikings will get
this in gold the samurai will get this
in silver and the Knights will get this
in bronze everybody in the game gets
this as long as you had participated in
the season which is pretty much playing
the game and then you will get this
ornament so just depends on the color
you'll be seeing the Viking version
which is in gold and it looks fantastic
I think this really belongs on the
Knights though as it seems to resemble
more of the guard stance icons that we
use in the game but since the Viking
shield there's a circle it looks a
little bit wonky and weird either way
it's very simple and minimalistic and
I'm in love with it next up is the
emblem this is usually the least cared
about part of the faction war but I feel
like it got even worse due to the fact
that as you're seeing on screen it's an
exact copy of the truth of why Verndale
two emblem - the color detail it looks
like a lot worse version of it I guess
it makes sense though seeing
the emblem that the original one we
talked about the truce of our Verndale -
is a paid version that you get in the
past so this is kind of like the non
paid version so obviously the non paid
version is going to be less of quality
so with that context in mind it makes a
little bit more sense
either way I'm probably not going to be
putting this on my characters anytime
soon and then lastly we have the
ornaments and these are faction based
meaning depending on which faction is it
equipped on it will change and this also
needs an explanation as well and this is
far by far the most complicated one to
understand if you are reading this in
the wrong context so these are only
accessible to the players who are a part
of the Viking faction players who earn
this or can use the emblem on any hero
it's not it's not just the Viking
characters only it's any hero in the
game you just need to be a part of the
winning faction in order to do this and
as you'll be seeing in the game playing
and the picture shown I'm a Viking and
they won so I get an ornament for every
character with that out of the way let's
get into these ornaments the first one
is the Knights and the ornament is going
to be called the lustrous Abbess kay I'm
just gonna call it lustrous for the
remainder of the video and that's what
it seems to be named for every single
faction it seems to have this nice
circular pattern and not the more
sharper ones were used to they seem more
elegant rather than edgy and you'll
notice on screen the colors changing
that's just me showing where the color
spots of the ornament change and how
drastic they are or aren't next up is
the Vikings this is a more tall
lengthwise version as opposed to the
previous ornaments Heights this seems to
have a lot less color changing in it
compared to the Knights but it is still
somewhat noticeable it also seems to
have some Wolf's on the edges as well
next up is the samurai and I chose hito
carry to kind of get that shoulder view
of it as the Year three heroes have a
different placement of where their
ornaments are compared to the rest of
the cast in the game this version seems
to have flames on the edges of the
ornament and that's a lot bigger than
the other ornaments that we've seen
before any character with a reigning
inferno gear or anything fire related or
red even should probably put this on as
it would probably fit the character
assuming the people putting these on
don't have ornaments already
for that specific character it seems
though that the flames are the only
thing being colored though which kind of
sucks lastly for the whole video is the
rule in another more elegant looking
piece with about 95% of the ornament
being influenced by the team color that
you choose so do with that as you will
out of these ornaments though I gotta
say ranking from worst to best we gotta
go samurai Knights Viking and ruled in
something about the ability to have most
of it being color changed it looks
really nice on some characters and
that's a huge bonus for me so as a quick
recap the Vikings which are the
first-place winners you guys are going
to be getting everything we just
mentioned which is the ornaments the
emblem and the outline for second place
which in this case is the samurai you
guys will be getting the emblem and the
outline and then third place which is
the Knights you guys will just be
getting the outline and remember what
the outline which we stated before
depending on which place you were in the
faction war is a different color Vikings
is gold samurai is silver knights is
bronze in the context of this season
yeah now that that is over guys do it
that is you will let me know in the
comments down below which ones you think
is cool do you think the outline looks
cool is the emblem nice you know was
this a better than last season's I know
the faction war buddy isn't cared about
too much as the Vikings are on this like
11 game season win streak or some [ __ ]
they just keep winning and I could
totally understand why and why a lot of
people have been switching to the
Vikings because of all that it kind of
sucks because it's kind of dampening the
experience of the faction more but but I
kind of understand is the rewards that
we get aren't exactly top tier or really
really nice and worth of getting to
especially since we don't know what the
reward is we kind of just hope that oh
if we win it might be a good ornament
this time it's all a toss-up if they
added executions and gave us what those
executions really were as like a preview
then I think that a lot of people would
be fighting in the faction more a lot
more by the way that's all the time we
have for today guys thank you all for
coming out to the video like the VP do
enjoy subscriber if it new I cover the
informational side of foreigner and with
that take care have a girls today and
peace out
[Music]
[Music]